Speaker 1: Welcome back to the David Pakman show.
I am Farron Cousins sitting in for David Pakman.
You can find me on YouTube at youtube.com, slash
fair and balanced and youtube.com slash the
ring of fire. And of course, every week I
hope to host the Ring of Fire podcast. Go
to our O.f podcast dot com. Well, we've got more
COVID news to talk about, and it actually calls
back to a story we talked about yesterday. As
you'll recall, we showed the clip of Donald Trump
and Bill O'Reilly, their Little Rewrite History
tour, where Donald Trump sheepishly admitted
that he had in fact gotten the COVID booster. The
crowd booed him. They did not want to hear that.
And then Bill O'Reilly this week does an
interview with Dan Abrams on News Nation,
and O'Reilly admits to Abrams that he had to
console Trump after that crowd booed him after the
event. Of course, they weren't on stage when the
you know. Make him feel better part took place.
So here's what O'Reilly said. I told him that
today he called me, he was hurt by their reaction,
I said, This is good for you. This is good
that people see another side of you, not a
political side. You told the truth. You believe
in the facts. Your administration did it and you
should take credit for it because it did save,
I don't know, hundreds of thousands of lives.
So I'm just picturing the scenario in my head
because this wasn't even like backstage after the
event that O'Reilly had to go up to and be like,
Hey bud, you OK? No, this was like the next day.
Trump calls them and rallies, probably like, Oh
God. Yeah, hello. Oops! Tells us that they were
so mean to me. Yeah, but listen, hey, sometimes
it's OK. Sometimes it happens. Now listen,
as I said yesterday, I'm actually OK with Donald
Trump claiming he created the vaccine. Whatever
it takes to get these people vaccinated at this
point, right? But at the same time. You did this.
I mean, you were the only one who didn't appear in
that, you know, PSA with some of the other former
presidents who encourage people to get vaccinated,
you've openly expressed your disdain for wearing
masks like you're literally encouraging
your followers to not protect themselves,
even in your little diatribe that we talked
about. You still said if you don't want to
get it, don't get it. No mandates. No
mandates. You're driving them to this.
So you don't get to be upset when you're a little
Frankenstein's monster turns on its creator.
And that is exactly what happened here. The
Q people out there, they're now confused and
a little angry because they don't know how
to feel about Trump, because suddenly he's
he's promoting the vaccine. So rest assured we're
going to end up with a new conspiracy theory in
the next couple of days as to why Trump really
claimed to have been boosted. So I guarantee you
that's on the horizon, so be on the lookout
for that. But again, you made this possible.
By downplaying the pandemic, by suggesting
it was overblown, by repeatedly telling us
last year that all it's going to be gone soon.
Oh, everything is going to be fine. And then, of
course, not encouraging people to get vaccinated,
hiding your own vaccination status from people.
That drives them. To these horrible,
horrible decisions. And, of course,
contributed to their anti-vax ideology.
Believe it or not, that was not even the
weirdest thing that O'Reilly said during that
interview with Dan Abrams. He goes on to say,
I'm trying to tell President Trump, Run on your
record, he's going to run again. All right.
So Bill O'Reilly, who clearly is
in close contact with Donald Trump,
has spent several weeks with him, has spent
all their time with him throughout this year,
tells us that without a doubt Donald
Trump is running for president in 2024.
So that's something we also have to deal
with, something that also has to be addressed.
But to his statement, run on your record, what
record is that 400000 dead Americans in a pandemic
that you pretended wasn't a big deal, a trade war
with China, that you had no idea what the end goal
was, you just started it because you were, I
don't know, feeling a little weird that day.
Or is it your border wall that sitting down there
literally falling apart, washing away and rusting?
Zoos are about the only three things. Oh,
I'm sorry, tax cuts. You also cut taxes
for the wealthy and screwed over working class
people by taking away some of our deductions.
What else? I mean, for Real, what
else was Donald Trump's record here?
So, Bill, when you tell him run on your
record. You got to be a little more specific
than that because there's only a handful of
things the guy did and all of them are bad.
Right? There's no good thing when you look at
it from a purely nonpartizan political analysis.
What good thing happened during the Trump
administration? Are there truly any people
in this country who can look at that and
say, Oh, my life is better off today?
At the end of his administration than it was
at the beginning, he did something that made me
better, of course, the top 10 percent of income
earners, sure, they can say that 100 percent.
But the rest of the country know we can't
say that there was either no change or it
got worse. And of course, with the pandemic, it
got worse for everybody except the billionaires.
So I don't know that encouraging him to
run on his record is the smartest thing
unless, of course you want him to lose, which I
do. So yes, please run on your record and remind
people how horrible those four years were. Now
some people are probably thinking no fair. And he
did have an accomplishment. He packed the courts
with Republican hacks, and I'm going to counter
you on that and say that was not necessarily
Trump. That was Mitch McConnell. That would have
happened under any Republican president. Mitch
McConnell would have made that happen. So no,
I do not count that as a Trump thing. I count
that as a McConnell thing. And I know Trump would
probably be furious to hear people say that. But
hey, that's the reality under which we live today